The sub gap is over 9,000!!!!!!
that's a meme, good meme Felix. SUBSCRIBE TO T-SERIES
*clap clap BOOM spank fap fap fap*
IT AINT OVER TILL I SAY ITS OVER
For real though I'm really proud
of everyone, I can't believe we made it this far
it's honestly an achievement just-
A G H H NEVER GIVE UP
I'm not giving up
until T-Series goes
poof
there will be no more bro fists
I'm serious
I didn't think I'd have to do this
no more bro fists
until T-Gay
gets deleted
gets completely annihilated
I didn't wanna sink this low
but I must go all out just this once huh
Do you know how much it's gonna mean
To get that brofist?
Here, try it.
(Grunts)
That was a TEST you dumb-o
Until then,
Let's get into the terrible submissions guys
another week another meme
everyone
lets just
hello everyone
yahh
^^^^
Its rewind time
incredible *clap* *clap*
I'm sorry Will Smith
you can't rewind your career though
haha
unless you go on meme review
"I drew PewDiePie
for 24 hours straight"
godamn
I haven't even done  anything for myself for that long
"I did what I could to help
small youtuber ZHC"
see this is what I'm talking about
I understand that you look at your own life
and what you do
to be completely insignificant
and I %100 agree with by- assessment by the way
but
if we all work together
if we all do our part
we can do amazing things
look at this fanart
look at it
woah
holy damn
*laughs* T series
sub
memes
very niiice
godamn thats crazy
cLap CLap cLap clAP
bravo! Incredible
*laughs*
that's so sick
YouTubes copyright problem
oh jee- great
another week
another copyright issue
what is it now?
^^^^^
*laughs* what the frick Youtube???
Lannan I'm sorry man just stop stealing poor tuogex1s content
alright?
this is the Youtube copyright system
Its- its- *laughs* It's free for all okay?
It's everyone against everyone
"just met Pewds 10/10"
thank you for rating my acquaintance 10/10
verry niicee
"also can confirm he has no legs
and was hovering"
well well well
I think this finally settles it doesnt it? huh?
all you doubters and haters and meaners
well well well
concrete- concrete evidence
I expect no more rumors and no more lies
being spread around this
a lot of people have been complaining about the camera quality
and like how the autofocus is wrong
and I just wanted to say...
I'm doing my best here guys okay?
I think I'm going to change up my err
framing
I'm gonna do it like the twitch girls, I mean like the people on websites
this is my new crop
just so you bros can see the merch better
New Merch everyone, link in the description
alright
*in high pitched voice* ehh the quality ohhh the lighting  is so bad pewds *inaudible*
*normal voice* oh yeah? hows that?
is that better lighting for you?
this is what you get now
you- you did this to yourself
^^^^
w h a t?!
sUb To peW Die Pie
^^^^^
wow
earn up votes from memes
it's a reddit inside Minecraft
"fully customizable
and for a good cause
%50 goes to charity"
and the other %50 goes to me
thats awesome, thanks guys thanks guys *claps*
thank you thank youuuu
50 percent goes to me right?
Roblox
oh yeah so these are the livestreams we've done
oh  god Happy wheels
godammit we have happy wheels
I though i was done after minecraft *laughs*
I dont wanna play happy heels
but I guess i willl
because I'm doing my part
I'm- I wake up everyday doing my part boboboboo